[Music]
welcome to this episode of click to
deploy a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions from the
google cloud marketplace
in this episode we'll be reviewing how
to set up a wordpress website via the
cloud marketplace in case you're
unfamiliar wordpress is a free open
source content management system used to
build custom websites
let's start by searching for wordpress
in the marketplace
since wordpress is open source you'll
see that we have a few different
deployment options from different
vendors
each deployment may be deployed with
different operating systems security
patches or server shapes for this demo
we'll choose the google click to deploy
virtual machines option
the landing page will display
information about the deployment pricing
and support
the pricing information displays a
high-level estimate of charges
once deployment options are picked we'll
receive a more detailed breakdown
it's important to review the additional
details to understand the technical
details for the deployment
we can see that a single vm will be
deployed on compute engine running the
debian os at version 9.13
we can also see all of the packages that
will be installed on the vm
let's begin the
[Music]
launch let's pick a deployment name end
zone in this case i'll go with the
default zone us east 4b
i'll also stick with the default machine
type which is an e2 small
the machine type chosen should
correspond with how much traffic load
you are expecting on your wordpress site
we'll choose an email address that we'll
use for our php admin account
we'll also stick with all the default
storage and networking options
lastly let's allow source traffic from
the internet via both http and https
before you deploy you can see your final
estimate of charges for the specific
options you choose to deploy
by clicking details you can see how
these costs break down
[Music]
we'll launch and give our deployment a
minute to spin up
[Music]
the next page will show us all the
information about our specific
deployment
clicking the site address will display
our default wordpress website
[Music]
we're provided all of the admin
connectivity and login information for
both wordpress and mysql
we're also given the ability to ssh
directly into our wordpress server
you'll also see that we're given some
suggested next steps like changing
temporary passwords and assigning a
static public ip address
let's log in as the wordpress admin and
change the password
[Music]
there we go
after we change mysql passwords we're
ready to start customizing our wordpress
site and configure a domain
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button below
we encourage you to check out the gcp
marketplace and deploy this solution on
your own
thanks for watching
you